con un palacio nacional completamente
amurallado y un despliegue de más de
tres mil mujeres policías para vigilar
esta movilización miles de mujeres han
salido a las calles en la ciudad de
mexico que iban a protestar maría de
lourdes cuál es tu motivo para estar hoy
aquí
aquí en este país cada mujer cada día
son asesinadas 1 de 10 mujeres es por
eso que voy alza la voz contra esta
violencia
quizá cual este motivo para estar hoy
aquí no estás sola la verdad no estás
sola y cuántas son todas nosotras
siempre
gracia en los delitos contra las mujeres
son los de alto impacto que no han
podido reducirse tal es así que 2021 ha
sido el año con más feminicidios en la
historia de mexico
2006 es por ello que han salido a las
calles muchas mujeres jóvenes pero
también madres de familia con hijas
desaparecidas con hijas asesinadas y
también podemos ver familias con niñas
todas a una sola voz exigiendo justicia